-Welcome back, everybody.
We are here with Adam Sandler!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, let's talk
"Murder Mystery 2,"
'cause I think
this is gonna be giant.
But it's you
and Jennifer Aniston.
The first one was like
the biggest --
I think it was the most
popular thing on Netflix.
-Of that year it was, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Just to say that is crazy.
-That feels good.
-We love Jennifer Aniston.
-Great young lady.
-You guys have
a great chemistry.
-Love her very much.
I know Jennifer
since we're very young.
I was 22.
She was 20.
I met her at a delicatessen.
She was with
a good friend of mine.
They were hanging out.
I sat down.
She had eggs.
I was eating French toast.
-You have a really good memory.
-Well, I remember
everything, yes.
I had chocolate milk
that morning.
And a crazy straw.
-Holy moly.
I can't believe
you remember all this.
-I didn't finish it.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't believe you remember
all these details.
-I blew bubbles.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I want to talk about this
because this is the sequel.
You guys are now
a detective agency.
-Yes, we're a married couple.
We have -- We quit --
Last movie, we did pretty well,
and we figured out some crimes,
right, some "moi-ders."
And we figured out
who "moi-derlized" everybody.
"You moi-dered me."
And then this movie,
Jennifer quit her job
as a --
she worked at a hair salon.
I quit my job as a cop, and we
become detectives together.
It's not going well.
We are not very good at it.
Then the maharaja
from the first movie
invites us to his wedding,
and turns out
the maharaja gets kidnapped.
Can you believe it?
So guess what.
Jennifer and I
try to solve who did it.
-Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's bigger.
It's action-packed.
-It is.
-It is global.
This one is massive. Dude.
-Yes.
-Eiffel Tower thing --
Am I spoiling something?
-No. Jennifer falls off
the Eiffel Tower in it.
-Yeah, but it's --
I read somewhere, like,
they've never even done a scene
on the top of the Eiffel tower
in the history of film.
-It was very cool.
They did it like
2:00 in the morning,
'cause when you go to Paris,
you go to to see
the Eiffel Tower.
-Of course.
-So they were like,
"You can shoot there, but do it
at like 2:00 in the morning
so we're not ruining
everybody's time."
-They come to Paris. Yeah.
-Yeah, so we shot at 2:00
in the morning,
and Jennifer's stunt girl,
Kelly,
she went out there
and swung on a rope.
It was really cool.
-From the top of the --
It's so great.
It's cool to watch.
I know. Someone's like...
Yeah, it's great.
-Scary, scary.
-The movie's fantastic.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Adam Sandler
in "Murder Mystery 2."
Take a look at this.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-But what about the colonel?
What's his motive?
-Well, maybe he just is sick
of working for rich people
'cause you guys suck.
Or maybe the colonel
needed enough money
to afford himself a bionic arm.
-I looked into it.
They're not very expensive.
-How much are we talking?
-20, 30K.
-That's it?
Geez, maybe I should get
something like that.
-You're gonna have to lose
an arm for that.
-I wasn't talking
about for the arm.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on! That's a stud!
-You know what I'm saying.
-That is a stud!
-Handsome bastard.
-That's a handsome man.
-One of the best-looking men
in America.
-Adam Sandler, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Murder Mystery 2"
premieres globally
on Netflix this Friday.
They love you. Standing ovation.
-I love you guys.
-More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on.